SPEAKER: In this
video, we're going
to go through how
you can migrate
a workload-- in this
case, the payment
service for an online store
from a virtual machine
to a GKE Autopilot cluster.
Before I dive into
the core of the demo,
let me say this demo
assumes you are already
familiar with both Migrate
for GKE and GKE Autopilot.
If you're not, you might
want to pause the video
and go get a quick overview
of both of these offerings,
and then come back
and rejoin me.
With that being
said, let's go ahead
and take a look
at where we're at.
This is our initial
architecture.
You can see the payment service
is there on the left in blue,
and it's running in a VM.
When we're done,
that will be migrated
to a container like
all the other services
in the online boutique.
So let's go ahead and take a
look at that online boutique
and see it actually in action.
So I'm going to go
here, and I'm going
to click on this barista set.
I'm going to add to
cart, and I'm just going
to go down and place my order.
And you can see everything
works as expected.
Lastly, before we jump
into the migration,
I want to show you the
infrastructure real quick.
I have two GKE
clusters, one running
Migrate for GKE, the other
running the sample application.
You can see that's
an Autopilot cluster.
Now, if I click
on Workloads, you
can see all of the
services running there
for the online boutique.
To perform the actual
migration, I'll
start by running an
analysis using Migrate
for GKE's migration fit tool
to see if our workload is
a good candidate for migration.
Next, I'll create
a migration plan,
and I edit it to
specify that we want
to enable the
resulting container
to run on GKE Autopilot.
From there, I'll execute
the actual migration.
This will result in
a set of artifacts,
including a Docker
file, a container image,
and a pair of YAML files--
one to deploy the Kubernetes
services and deployment
and another to manage
the configuration
of those primitives.
I'll then deploy the
newly migrated workload
using the Kubernetes YAML.
Finally, I'll edit
the configuration
for the currently
running services
to point them to the newly
deployed Kubernetes service,
replacing the virtual machine's
DNS name with the Kubernetes
service name.
The first step in
any migration process
should be to ensure that
the targeted workload is
a good candidate for migration.
With the 1.8 release
of Migrate for GKE,
we've introduced via public
preview a new migration fit
assessment tool.
This tool can operate against
VMs running on VMware vSphere
by directly interacting
with the vSphere APIs
or it can be run directly
against a single VM.
In the case of our
demo today, I'm
operating directly on
the VM I want to migrate,
which happens to be running
on Google Compute Engine.
But like I said, it could just
as easily be running on VMware.
Additionally,
Migrate for GKE also
supports migrating workloads
from AWS and Azure.
Let's go ahead and take a
look at the fit assessment
tool in action.
I'll run the fit
assessment tool,
which will gather information
about the processes
and services running on my VM.
Then I'll import
the resulting data,
which is stored in a TAR
file into the fit assessment
database.
I can use the ls command
to get a list of VMs
that I've gathered
data from previously.
Next, I'll have the
fit tool analyze
the collected information.
Once it's finished
its assessment,
I will have it produce a
report on its findings.
The report can be
in HTML or JSON.
I'm going to specify JSON, so
I can upload it to the Google
Cloud console later.
Also, while I'm only analyzing
a single VM in this demo,
you can batch process
this analysis.
Now that I have the
report, I'm going
to upload it to the
Google Cloud console,
and you can see the result here.
My application is a
good fit for migration.
If I want to see exactly
what was found on the VM,
I can drill down and take a look
here at some of the details.
Before I can actually migrate
a VM, I need to stop it.
So let me move into the
shell here and issue the stop
instances command.
I'll speed up the video a little
bit and when that's finished,
we can move on.
So I've already created
a processing cluster
and defined a source, so
let's define our migration.
We'll click Create Migration.
I'm going to call
it paymentservice.
We're going to select the
source I created earlier.
It's Linux, and the VM
name is paymentservicevm.
We're going to use
the image intent.
We'll click Create Migration
and wait for that to finish.
All right, now, we can move on.
So let's go in and edit
the actual migration plan.
Now, I need to make
a change in here
to ensure that the
resulting containers can
run on Autopilot.
So I'll come in and I'm going
to add an annotation up here
near the top.
So I'll hit Enter and I'll
paste the annotation in.
Then I'm going to
scroll down and I
want to change the
service in the image name
from paymentservicevm
to just paymentservice.
So we'll change it here
and we'll change it here.
We'll click Generate Artifacts.
That will take a
few minutes, so I'm
going to speed up this video and
rejoin you when it's finished.
The migration is finished and
I've downloaded the resulting
artifacts into Cloud
Shell, so let's take
a look at the config.yaml file.
The config.yaml file
is used to control
a bunch of different aspects
of the container that's
going to run, including
what processes are running
in the container, some
things about the file system
and how it's laid out.
Now, I'm not going to
spend a lot of time here.
I just wanted you to
be aware of this file
because you may have to
edit it in the future.
So let's go ahead and apply the
deployment_spec.yaml that was
generated.
This is going to create
two Kubernetes primitives,
the service and the deployment.
So let's go ahead and
take a look at the pods
and see if our new service
is up and running yet.
It looks like it's
actually still pending,
so I'm going to pause
the video and I'll
rejoin you once it's started.
OK, it's been a few minutes.
Let's clear the screen
and take another look.
And it looks like our
pod is up and running.
So let's go ahead now, we'll
clear the screen again,
and then what we're
going to do is
we're going to go ahead and
check out the online boutique.
Let's go ahead and
get the services
so we can get that
external IP address.
And we'll copy that up,
and we'll paste it in here,
and let's try to buy something.
So the camera, add to cart,
complete the purchase.
You see an error.
Now, that's because while I
have the new service running,
my VM is stopped and
the application is still
trying to access it.
So what I need to do is I need
to edit the deployment spec
for the actual application.
And right here, you
can see where we set
that payment service address.
So let me change that from
the DNS name of the VM
to the service name of
the Kubernetes service.
I'll save that out.
We'll go back into
the command line,
and I'll apply that
deployment spec so
that we can update the
services to look not at the VM,
but at that new container
we just deployed.
So we'll apply that out.
You can see all
the configuration
changes coming along here.
And now, I'm going to
go ahead, once again,
make sure that the
pods have started up.
Looks like the pod has
started up successfully.
So let's go ahead and move
back to the online boutique,
and let's try to buy
that camera again.
So we'll click Add to Cart.
We'll click Place Order, and
everything works as expected.
We have migrated
the payment service
from the virtual
machine to a container
running on GKE Autopilot.